انا كنت متوجه
من متوجه لتغطيه ح تغطيه صحفيه يعني في
مخيم جباليه مدارس
الايواء فجاه صار انفجار ضخم انا شعرت
باثر
الانفجار للحظات الاولى ما حسيت
باصابات مع اني تحركت يعني مسافه للوراء
تقريبا الانفجار كان بعيد عني 10
متر كنت شايف قدامي طبعا ناس كثافه الناس
ماشيين في الطريق وهدول صار فيهم انفجار
مسكت الكاميرا حاولت اصور يعني حدث
كالعاده لكن بعد ثواني
اي تحسست الاصابات شعرت انه في اصابه في
كتفي واصابه في الرقبه واصابه في
الحوط وبعد هيك ما بعرف شو اللي صار غبت
عن الوعي ولقيت حالي في المركز ال كنا
متوجهين من منطقه جبال البلد على معسكر
جباليا تغطيه الاحداث في
المخيم فجاه في منطقه الشارع الرئيسي
للمخيم كنت انا وزميلي اسلام بدر فجاه في
مسافه في بيننا وبين الانفجار اكثر من 10
متر صار انفجار شديد في المكان بشكل مباشر
انتبهت انه انا مصاب في
رجلي وبعديها ما فهمتش ايش اللي
صار الان حاولت الاصابات كانت شضايا تجي
على الوجه عندي حتى كمان صار انه الدرع
هنا خزق الدرع هذه اصابه كانت لكن قدر
ربنا وحما حمايه ربنا كانت موجوده وعنايه
ربنا الان شردنا تخبيت ورا باص صغير لحد
ما اشوف الوضع كيف وين الدخنه وين الضربه
جريت خطوتين ما قدرت فوقعت على الارض لانه
ما قدرت امشي على رجلي زعقت على زميلنا
اسلام انه انا متصاوب فجاوبني ان هو كمان
متصاوب فبعدين اجوا الناس نقلونا على
المستشفى وجامونا ه حتى الان الشديه ضاي
داخل رجل انهم يعملوا ل العمليه طول
الشديه ان شاء الله